مع اقتراب أشهر الصيف، هل سنشهد
حركة احتجاجية متجددة أم أن
عمليات الإعدام هذه سيكون لها تأثير مروع أم
أكثر، لقد انضممت إلي آزاد بوزاند، وهي
زميلة بارزة في مركز
النظام العالمي للشرق الأوسط، وتركز كتاباتها
على حرية التعبير في إيران  أو
ربما الافتقار إليها هو ما
تركزون عليه يوميًا، وأتساءل ما الذي
تعتقد أنه وراء استئناف
هذه الإعدامات،
نعم شكرًا لك على استضافتي بشكل جيد كما
أعتقد أن جمهورية إيران الإسلامية هي
نظام يفعل ذلك منذ أكثر من عام.  أربعة
عقود اختبرت تأثير
إعدامات أه وعامة الناس وهي
أم من خلال تجربة الاعتقاد بأنها
يمكن أن تستخدم بشكل فعال عمليات إعدام عقوبة الإعدام
كوسيلة لغرس أم الخوف
وكأسلوب تخويف وقد
استخدمته تاريخيا على وجه الخصوص في
في مناطق الأقليات العرقية في إيران على سبيل
المثال في المناطق الكردية أو
مناطق البلوش التي لديها
حصة غير متناسبة من عمليات الإعدام
كل عام، وأعتقد في هذه المرحلة
ما إذا كنا ننظر إلى
عمليات الإعدام المرتبطة بالاحتجاج أو
عمليات الإعدام غير المرتبطة بالاحتجاج والتي  كما ارتفعت
في رأيي أن كلاهما يخدم
نفس الغرض وهو أن النظام
يأمل أن يكون
أسلوب تخويف فعال بشكل أساسي
لمنع وتفريق أي
احتجاجات وانتفاضات أخرى من شأنها أن تكون في
الأساس استمرارًا لما
رأيناه في العام الماضي
إذن، ما رأيك في
رد فعل المجتمع الدولي في
أعقاب وفاة ميسر مباشرة وفي
سلسلة عمليات الإعدام الأصلية وما الذي
تعتقد أنه يجب القيام به في هذه
المرحلة،
نعم، كما ترى، أعتقد أنه اه، كما
تعلم  قضايا إيران هي قضية معقدة
لأنك إذا نظرت إلى قضية فأنت تعلم أنك
تنظر إليها يومًا بعد يوم أه تعلم أنك
ترى أن المجتمع الدولي
والغرب قد تعلم أنه قام بأشياء مثل
البيانات المشتركة كما ترى
أم أنك تعرف أنك تعرف انتهاكات إيران
لحقوق الإنسان  حقوق الإنسان، وخاصة
عقوبة الإعدام، التي ستطرح في الأمم المتحدة.
ترى آليات مختلفة تلعب دورها
بطرق سلمية من أجل دفع
إيران إلى أن تكون لاعبا مسؤولا وأكثر
مسؤولية على
الساحة الدولية، ولكن في الوقت نفسه أعتقد
أن هذا النظام هو  لا يُظهر أنه قابل
للتصحيح، إنه قابل للإصلاح، إنه غير
خاضع للمساءلة إلى حد كبير، وثقافة
عدم المساءلة بشكل أساسي
هي ما أه مستمر، لذا في رأيي، يتعين
علينا في الأساس
أن يكون المجتمع الدولي
أكثر قوة وأكثر من ذلك بكثير
نحو محاسبة الجمهورية الإسلامية
ومحاسبة الأفراد
والكيانات المتورطة بشكل أساسي في ما
هو الحرمان التعسفي من أه الحياة
في هذه القضية والانتهاكات الجسيمة لحقوق
الإنسان هنا
نتحدث عن النظام الذي أظهر
مرارا وتكرارا أنه ليس كذلك  الذهاب إلى
إصلاح نفسها إلا إذا أه ما لم تواجه بالفعل
إجراءات عقابية من قبل
القضاء الدولي يعني في
رأيي نعم من
الصعب جدًا جدًا أه أن أه حقًا
نوع من السياج الدائري
الذي يمكن للمجتمع الدولي أن يفعله
في هذه المرحلة ولكنك  هل قمت
بطعنة جيدة جدًا في هذا الأمر، يبدو أننا
رأينا مجموعة واسعة من النشاط النشط
في مجتمع الشتات الإيراني وقد
قمنا بإعداد تقرير عن الكثير منه منذ
بداية هذا سبتمبر في
مهرجان كان السينمائي الإيراني  ارتدت عارضة الأزياء
فستانًا مزودًا بحبل مشنقة لجذب
الانتباه إلى عمليات الإعدام في إيران، وقد
انتقدها البعض على أنها استغلت هذه
الفرصة كنوع من محاولة
الترويج لنفسها على السجادة الحمراء،
وأتساءل ما الذي فعلته من هذا ما
تفعله من هذا النوع  النشاط وما
إذا كنت تعتقد أنه يساعد حقًا
نعم، حسنًا، أنت تعلم أعتقد أنني أعتقد أيضًا أنني
رأيت النقد الذي قرأته وإلى
حد ما، كما تعلم،
كان شعوري الشخصي أيضًا أنه كان كذلك، كما
تعلم أنه كان قليلاً
لقد تم ذلك بطريقة لم أكن
معتادًا عليها على الأقل ولكن ما أريد أن أسمع
تسليط الضوء عليه هو دور الإيرانيين
في الخارج، لقد قام الشتات الإيراني في
رأيي بعمل رائع ورائع
في الأشهر الثمانية الماضية حقًا في
توصيل صوت ما هو  يحدث
داخل البلاد ويتردد صداه على
المستوى الدولي، وإذا كنت
تتحدث على الأقل عن
الديمقراطيات الغربية، فأنت تعرف أن رفع مستوى الوعي
بين عامة الناس سواء كان ذلك
في فرنسا أو في الولايات المتحدة أو في المملكة المتحدة وما إلى ذلك،
نأمل أن يؤدي إلى الضغط بشكل أساسي
على هذه الحكومات في الغرب أن
تبذل المزيد من الجهد من أجل
محاسبة الجمهورية الإسلامية،
فبينما تقف الانتقادات وبعض الحالات على
هذا النحو في رأيي الشخصي، ما
زلت لا أريد تجاهل
أهمية النشاط
أم  أه النشاط الإيراني وخارجه في
كل مكان وكل ساحة دولية
لأننا نتحدث عن
نظام شديد الوحشية والعنف
يقتل الأطفال والشباب يوما بعد يوم